here's a story that's about to get me in
trouble and i turned around and i see
ashton's face and he was like
no
mila kunis knows we love a good
parenting fail story and this one is a
doozy instead of like being frustrated
we were like oh my god the actress and
her husband ashton kutcher are parents
to two kids seven-year-old daughter
wyatt and a four-year-old son dimitri i
can write you a book in all kid-friendly
activities anywhere in the world okay
but there's one chapter of that book
where you won't find mila and her hubby
on the same page what's a trait of yours
that your child has that you wish they
didn't oh
my daughter is me
and she is independent
in the newest episode of bomb
confessions which posed to the ellen
degeneres show's youtube channel mila
opens up about the time ashton was taken
aback by her motherly advice
what's your biggest parenting fail well
so there was a little kid in my kids
preschool that wasn't very kind and
pushed my daughter my daughter came back
and she was like so such and such little
kiddo pushed me well despite knowing
each other for over two decades mila
proves she can still surprise her
partner and i instinctually said did you
push her back
and my daughter's like no and i was like
push your back next time you push your
back and you say no thank you and you
walk away and i turned around and i see
ashton's face and he was like
no but hey at least mila is all about
safety i was like don't push him off of
a ladder or off of a swing or off of a
slide but like on the ground even
stephen you push him back
i'd say that that's a parenting fail
okay so there was some differing
opinions in that instance but overall
mom and dad still subscribe to the same
parenting philosophy i think it's
incredibly important and amazing mila
opened up to et about how her and ashton
try to set a good example for their kids
by helping others i mean you guys do
give back so much i know you also do
such incredible work with trafficking
how much do you talk about that in your
own house like how is that something you
want to instill in your kids one day
that giving back spirit
i mean i think that hopefully you'd lead
by example so it's we don't necessarily
talk about it but maybe that's not
really true because we have to go to
things like this and
when it comes to thorn
um
it's hard to to talk to a seven and a
five year old about the the purpose of
thorn but i think we talk about like
mommy and daddy try to help people so i
guess we do talk about that mila also
reflected on her and ashton's role in
one of this year's biggest social media
debates i'm sure you're you're sick of
talking about but if you want to do
another 10 minutes on the bath debate i
don't think i'm aware of how many people
weighed in i was in a different country
when this when this storm hit bleep it
out if you must but i um it didn't i
didn't i don't think that i was aware
honestly of what was happening with
but it's great listen if it gets
people's mind off of reality who cares
honestly thank you for that yeah
whatever people may laugh that's great